aujourd'hui c'est la journée nationale
du fromage alors évidemment l'une des
premières questions qu'on se pose c'est
pourquoi y at il des trous dans certains
fromages les maple est un fromage à pâte
cuite et presser pendant la finale
une armée de micro-organismes découpe
les protéines et les lipides contenus
dans l'est et les transforment en arômes
notamment des chercheurs suisses ont
récemment découvert qu'il y avait aussi
de toutes petites particules de foi qui
en fermentant produisait du gaz comme
l'emmenthal est recouvert d'une croûte
étanche ce gaz ne parvient pas à
s'échapper
ils forment des bulles qui deviennent
des trous quand on découpe le fromage ça
sent bon
une vraie capsule 2d confiné aller à
demain et n'oubliez pas nous sommes
confinés
mais en restant lien si vous avez aimé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à laisser un
pouce bleus gens réalisent une nouvelle
chaque jour alors pour ne rater aucune
de ces capsules 2d confiné abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche
merci à toutes et à tous et à demain